a local priest efforts crucial in
getting our community vaccinated he is
the faith leader who made access to
church services possible even when the
church's doors were forced to close
we're sharing his story as we celebrate
hispanic heritage month
it's a very
diverse community
father rafael pereira serves a
faith-based community in las vegas of
about 500 members most of them are from
mexico but we have from all over you
know from south america from central
america and and also a lot of
hispanic that they they were born here
in the united states
when the pandemic hit many joyous
occasions typically celebrated were
replaced with somber ones now sometimes
be with them you know in the
when they are in the hospital when they
passed away so that's that's been very
challenging not to mention the statewide
shutdown and eventual limit on
gatherings at houses of worship all
saints episcopal church was forced to
close its doors march 15th of 2020. we
closed the building but we never go
if parishioners couldn't come to him he
was going to find a way to reach them
and he did through technology and social
media preaching through a camera to no
one in in the building but yeah it was
very very uh without the spirituality of
having you know everybody in the church
praying singing and now i was alone
through a camera to reach them
what proved to be a challenge at first
turned into an ability to expand his
outreach before the pandemic
you just reach your community here in
las vegas but now you know you could
reach the whole world even friends
families sharing the services in italy
in spain in venezuela and all over now
they are part of the community father
pereira also serves on the board of the
health department spearheading efforts
to get his community vaccinated he
really stepped up to the plate to not
only offer his church as a vaccination
site but really to serve as that trusted
faith leader to create awareness through
his social platforms it was really
impactful for me to have that support in
him in our community doing
get that such a fantastic man we
appreciate all he does